i'm jealous of someone you used to hang
out with you you actually got to hang
out with david bowie i am such a bowie
fan like bowie to me you know how you
feel about broadway i feel about david
bowie i love the story where you got to
know david bowie and you told him
because you love broadway yeah i'm
taking you to see the play rent like you
said to bowie i want to take you and
iman yes we were out to dinner and i
said we're going to see rant and he's
like i'm not doing it and i'm like
you're doing it and you're going to sit
next to me and next to iman on the other
side and it's getting rave reviews and
the guy is gonna you're gonna be he died
on opening night david it's very big
except so we went there and he leaned
over after like you know 20 minutes and
said i'm going to kill you
and i was like come on man he's like
kill you and then uh
we got out of there and he said here's
what you're going to do you're going to
come to nobu with me and iman i'm gonna
order and you're gonna eat every [ __ ]
thing i ordered because he knew i was
afraid of sushi and he couldn't believe
that i was afraid of sushi meanwhile who
loves sushi more than you i will be nobu
every night any city any night